between 1909 and 1952 some 30,000 Morgan
three-wheelers were built in Malvern
England this f2 two-seater built in 1936
is one of the last examples of a very
special type of vehicle it took more
than a year to restore the vintage car
to its original condition
Morgan's reasons for building the 3
wheeler were not so much technical as
economic
yeah dharma Liga marked against over
from a Morgan dealership in düsseldorf
explains that back then vehicle tax made
driving a four wheeled vehicle very
expensive in England but there was the
option of registering a three-wheeled
vehicle as a motorcycle that made
mobility much more affordable for young
families which and if you need to give a
cut so extroyer since 2012 this piece of
automotive history has returned in the
form of a new model for yen Stover and
the many other three wheeler enthusiasts
around the world it's a special comeback
despite the modern technology under the
hood drivers can feel like they're
sitting behind the wheel of a rolling
time machine where else can you putter
down the road in such style
as a personal yen says that part of the
appeal of driving a three wheeler is in
the purism of it unlike with a
four-wheel car you feel your
surroundings more immediately
there's no windshield and side windows
so you experience everything more
intensely this reveal of Harvin's some
things never change
morgan has been building vehicles for
more than 100 years and even today all
its products have one thing in common
they're made by hand in more than some
200 kilometers northwest of London 200
mechanics and engineers assemble around
1,000 vehicles each year
the SNS v2 engine has 82 horsepower it's
five-speed transmission is from the
Mazda mx-5 weighing only 525 kilograms
the morgan reaches a speed of 185 km/h
but this snazzy set of wheels isn't a
budget option it costs upwards of forty
two thousand three hundred euros but it
does come with an exciting bit of
automotive history
Yente server explains that Morgan
started making three wheelers in 1909
and they were so popular the company
decided to make more company founder
Henry Frederic Stanley decided to start
limited production for which he expanded
his factory but demand was so great he
kept expanding production until the
three wheeler was built continually
every year from 1909 until 1952 for
Launcelot law and besides that's why
infancy about about wasting it in
Germany the vehicle licensing authority
classifies three wheelers is not a cars
nor motorcycles but as a separate class
of their own the Morgans driving quality
is nothing to sneeze at even on turns in
the past people in Britain even took
part in motorsports with the three
wheelers
it's a sword as Morgan cats actually
feel yen's adds that in fact the Morgan
sent lots of records there were a number
of companies in England making three
wheelers and they fought some rather
fish jewels on the racetracks at the
time and the victors weren't necessarily
the fastest ones cause of that era had
to prove their practicality for daily
use in the trials if the car passed
successfully that showed people it was a
good one the trials like batter no
longer held now those are the classic
uphill climbs over hedge and ditch but
it's enough of an adventure to simply
pilot a three wheeler through the
streets it's like a combination of
driving a soapbox car and flying a
double-decker the lack of a windshield
means you're likely to have to pick bugs
out of your teeth and if it rains you're
out of luck it's a truly authentic
driving experience
but in a sense Stover points out driving
a three-wheeler is more like riding a
motorcycle with a similar feeling of
immediacy
you